Hey YouTubers it's Charlie. Because the
Doctor Who Christmas Special is this week
and there's so much talk about Clara
leaving I thought it'd be fun
to pick a new companion. Heads up to a
new round of the giveaway starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video,
it's a twenty dollar Amazon gift card, I just
pick at random. The way it reads right now,
Clara's probably gonna stay on for
up to half of Series 9, maybe less than
that. Jenna Coleman's been very cryptic about it
but Moffat spent so much time talking
about children and
teasing Frank Skinner in Orient Express
this year there'll probably be someone new whenever
Series 9 starts off.
They did a preview screening of the
Christmas Special a couple weeks ago and it
was revealed that Series 9
episode 1 is titled "The Magician's
Apprentice".
Do you not just love how much Moffat
and Capaldi are leaning into this
magician joke.
Can you just feel all the out-of-work Harry
Potter actors queueing
up at Moffat's door. Whatever ends up
happening, Clara's leaving soon
so everybody get your Doctor Clara
regeneration jokes ready.
I can just feel waves of puns coming
off of Tumblr. So I already talked a
little bit about people I'd like to see
as companions on Doctor Who before
Series 8 started but because of the way
things went down and the overall tone of the
show and the direction I think it should go in
I tried to adjust some of my picks. I really
love the idea of evil Clara
so I'd like to see a more
rugged companion, maybe not necessarily
an evil companion but someone who could play evil in a really fun way
without stepping on Michelle Gomez's toes.
And just because I'd like to see a tougher
companion, like a more
physically imposing companion doesn't
mean I'm stuck on it being male, but if
we're talking about a female Doctor
happening soon
then we should also talk about a male
companion happening soon. So here are my
top five picks for new companions
starting with number five: Ellis George
as Courtney Woods.
She doesn't really fit into my idea of a
battle-ready companion
but I feel like Moffat was keeping her
locked in the chamber of his gun
all year just in case Jenna Coleman
pulled the trigger. There was a good
chance that she was gonna leave in the
Christmas Special so I think he was just
having someone cued up ready to go.
Think of Courtney Woods as like the
safety pick. So that's why I put her on
this list.
She's like the default right now until Moffat finds a better companion.
We don't really know what his actual
plans are for Series 9 other than he's
really leaning into the idea of Capaldi being a wizard
which I am all on board for, I am totally
on board for the Doctor being a wizard.
Number four: Matthew Lewis from Harry
Potter. You probably remember him as Neville
Longbottom but right now he's on
Bluestone
playing a soldier so he fits really well
into my idea of a magician's apprentice.
He's played with a wand but look at him
now. I mean, he is literally
in a war zone. That doesn't mean I want
Capaldi to turn into a War Doctor,
I just, I want the Doctor to be more
aggressive, I want the show to be more
aggressive.
I really enjoyed the dark stories during
Series 8. I think it's a lot more fun
whenever the Doctor
charges in and causes more problems than
he solves. And think about his distaste
for soldiers.
It seems a little irrational at times
but I feel like having one on board the TARDIS
would just cause the scenes to crackle
with energy. Someone who has the
self-confidence
to not put up with any the Doctor's
bullcrap and who's not going to shy away
from a fight.
It'd just be so much fun to see a companion
who could punch someone in the face.
That's not really what Doctor Who is
about but I would like to see it drift
slowly in that direction,
at least for one series. I'm all for the
idea of Doctor Who characters solving
their problems using
ingenuity but it would be nice to see
them you some muscle
every once in a while. Number four: Ellie
Kendrick from Game of Thrones.
I'm mostly putting her on this list because of what
she did on Misfits, her Helen character.
She did a really good job of playing
both good and evil characters
and that's what I feel like a companion
should be. Clara only got a little bit evil
but she was a lot of fun, she was a lot of
fun when she was being crazy.
And that's totally Ellie Kendrick on
Misfits, I mean all those characters are crazy.
I'm really leaning towards a male
companion for the most part but I feel
like she would be an amazing
magician's apprentice. The added bonus is
she's not
so big, she's not blowing it up so hardcore that she's too expensive for
Doctor Who
and she's not too busy for it. That's one of
the big problems with a lot of the great actors
is they're already signed to other series,
or they're starting their film careers,
that's why Matt Smith left,
I mean his film career was taking off. So
Ellie Kendrick just checks all those boxes
and I feel like Game of Thrones could do
without her, like it doesn't need her.
Number two: Alexander Ludwig from Vikings.
Right now he's the adult son
of Ragnar and Lagertha on the show. It'd be
a little harder to get him
just because he's still alive on the show
and they're shooting a new season.
But because they also should in the UK he's
a little closer to Cardiff.
That's another big problem too,
lots of great actors out there but you
have to be in proximity to Cardiff 'cause
that's where Doctor Who shoots.
Really any number of actors from
Vikings would be awesome,
just, like, a really badass, tough companion.
I'd say Lagertha too but I feel
like she's too critical to that show, like
they're not gonna kill her off on Vikings
anytime soon.
And my number one pick for a new Doctor
Who companion:
Joe Dempsie from Game of Thrones,
although he's done a bunch other stuff recently.
A lot of people might remember him from
The Doctor's Daughter during David
Tennant's run.
There have been a lot of actors on Doctor Who
that have played lesser characters and gone on
to become the Doctor themselves
like in Classic Who. So there is
precedent for actors that have already
been on the show
to come back in a different role, but I feel
like Joe Dempsie can bring the
perfect kind of energy that I'm looking
for.
The downside to having him, as awesome as
that'd be, is that that may not be the
direction that Moffat wants to take the
show in.
Really the title, that Magician's
Apprentice title, makes it sound like
it's gonna be Harry Potter spinoff.
They do like to have fun with the titles and,
to be honest, a lot of the titles changed
during Series 8. Like there were titles
that we got early in the year,
some of those changed, some of those stayed the same. So it's probably gonna be a long time before we
know what's going down,
especially given that Moffat lies so
much and I say that in the nicest
possible way.
Let me know though who is your top pick
for a new companion. Do you want to see a
male companion?
Do you want to see another female companion? Someone older? Someone younger?
There's a good chance that the companion could
show up in the first episode of Series 9
and they're gonna be shooting that after
they shoot the Sherlock Christmas
Special in January.
So that's coming up really soon. Here are a couple
things that I think will absolutely not
happen.
One: I don't think it's going to be an
old companion. I think it'll be someone
closer to Jenna Coleman's age if not younger.
Number two: It's not going to be a really
young child. I don't think they'll go the Amelia
Pond route.
I could just feel the rage from all the
cringe-worthy moments from having, like, little
children on-screen all the time. Clara and Danny Pink at Coal Hill School
was totally awesome in Series 8, it was totally awesome to see the inside of that.
All the students, not so much. And three: it's
not gonna be someone with potential for
hanky-panky.
There will be no hanky-panky on the
TARDIS as the Doctor said. Just to do
some fictional casting just to have some fun:
Anwen Williams and Alfie Owens. That's
the daughter of
Gwen Cooper from Torchwood and Stormageddon.
I'd really like to see some fan fiction
where they start, like, a kid's detective
agency and start causing a bunch of trouble
and the Doctor has to get involved
because they uncover some Game of Thrones
level galactic shit.
That'd also be an awesome way to bring
John Barrowman back into the story.
Steven Moffat actually said he's totally
open to having Captain Jack back on the show
but only if his presence invigorates the
story, like he's not gonna bring him on just for fun.
So a couple important dates to remember.
Doctor Who Christmas Special happening
on the 25th. Everyone be sure to
watch it.
I will be posting my review like right
after the episode airs and then I'll be
posting a Q&A after that so be sure to
subscribe to get everything.
I'll try and do some more bonus videos too but I
will continue the giveaway for
like all my non-Q&A videos, like all the
bonus videos and the reviews I post
including this one. Congratulations to
It's the real music man, you're the winner
of this week's giveaway.
You win a twenty dollar Amazon gift card
so be sure to message me on my channel
for details.
Next round of the giveaway will start
whenever I post my Christmas Special review.
I might post a bonus video tomorrow so
if I do then they'll be another round of
the giveaway then.
I'm also working on a Sherlock bonus
video that I'll try and post sometime in
the next couple of days too.
Doctor Who has priority but I will be
doing Sherlock too. Right now if you're on
your mobile phone or on your talent there's new
links you can click on up here. It's the same as
the links over here. But click here for
all my Doctor Who Christmas Special
videos and click here to start getting
ready for Sherlock. Thank you so much for watching,
let's all high five, I'll see you guys tonight.